-Our first guest tonight is
a talented actor you know best
as Peter Parker from both
the "Spider-Man" movies
and the "Avengers" franchise.
He returns in
"Spider-Man: No Way Home,"
which premieres exclusively
in theaters and IMAX
on December 17th.
Let's take a look.
-That's right, folks.
Spider-Man is in fact
Peter Parker.
-Are you Spider-Man's
girlfriend?
Are you Spider-Man's girlfriend?
-Whoa, it's him!
-Uh, whoa, whoa, whoa.
Please don't touch her, sir.
-You're just a kid?
-You murdered Mysterio?
-Uh...
-You helped him murder Mysterio?
-No, I didn't --
-Come on, let's see that face.
-Whoa, whoa, whoa!
-All this time,
people looked up to this boy
and called him a hero.
Well, I'll tell you
what I call him --
public enemy number one!
-No, no, no! I told you I never
want to do this ever again!
-M.J., I'm so sorry,
but I can't see anything
with your hand in my --
-Sorry, I'm sorry!
[ Breathing rapidly ]
[ Cellphone vibrates ]
-Dude!
-[ Gasps ]
[ Laughter ]
-Please welcome back to the show
Tom Holland, everybody!
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
So nice to see you.
-Dude!
[ Laughter ]
I mean, I've been there.
That's how I get mobbed
when I walk out of the studio.
-It's tough, right?
-That was like watching a
documentary about my life, yeah.
-Another day in the life.
It's so nice to have you
here in studio.
Thanks for making the trip.
-Mate, it's so good to be back.
Thank you for having me.
-I want to mention that I have
not seen the film
because I understand, you know,
these Marvel things
are tight-wrapped.
-Yes.
-They sent me -- They said,
"Would you like to watch the
first 40 minutes of the film?"
-Right.
-I was like,
"I don't think I could do that.
I think it would just be too
hard to only watch 40 minutes
and then have to wait."
-It's like a really,
really offensive trailer.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-You know? It's really,
really unfair, that.
We've been showing the press
40 minutes of the film.
-Yeah?
-Just to kind of --
There's some really big stuff in
this film that we want to keep
a secret just because this film
really is the celebration
of three generations of cinema.
So we want to keep as much of it
back as possible.
It has been really interesting
only talking about
40 minutes of a movie, though.
-Right.
-But it's been fun and the press
have been really excited,
and it's been a really good
press tour so far.
-Do you ever feel like
you're in class
and the teacher's asked you
if you read the whole book
and you're faking it?
They're like,
"What was your favorite part
of 'Tale of Two Cities'?"
"The beginning. Oh."
-Yes, right, right, right.
-"Loved the beginning."
-That's like every movie
I've ever done
that's based off of a book.
The director's like, "So, what
did you think of the book?"
I'm like, "it's great.
It's so like the script."
[ Laughter ]
"It's so good." You know?
-You're like, "You know what?
I think once I see the movie
we're about to make, I'll have a
real understanding of the book."
[ Laughter ]
-We're on the same page.
-I know you're about to go L.A.
after this.
-Yes.
-You just did some London,
and then you get to go home,
thankfully, for the holidays.
Are you looking forward to going
back, being with your family?
-I am. I am.
I'm very stressed, though,
because, you know, naturally
with a press tour,
you're very busy -- I haven't
done any Christmas shopping yet.
-Yeah.
-I don't think I can say to
my family that me coming back
for Christmas
is enough of a gift.
-Right.
-But it is, right?
-Yeah, I mean, look.
-Come on. Who wants me to
come over for Christmas?
[ Cheers and applause ]
-I want to say this --
no exaggeration.
If you came and spent Christmas
with me, that would be enough.
-Right. Vice versa.
-Yeah. Thank you.
-Are we doing this?
Are we doing this?
-I think we're doing this.
Honey...
[ Cheers and applause ]
Honey, tell the kids
I'm not coming home.
I'm hanging out with Tom.
[ Laughter ]
I was wondering about
your family, 'cause I know
you're very close with
your brothers
and your family in general,
but they obviously understand
what you're going through
as far as how busy you are.
-Right.
-But they're not gonna let you
off the hook, are they?
-No.
-Yeah.
-They're really not, and I'm
gonna find myself Christmas Eve
running around like
a headless chicken,
buying socks, tea towels.
-Right.
-Meaningless stuff, you know?
Nice card.
I'll write a nice card.
"Dear Mum, merry Christmas.
Tom."
-You get a sweatshirt
that says "Heathrow."
-Yeah, exactly! Yeah.
"I love New York."
[ Laughter ]
-"These are very rare.
This is the only replica Statue
of Liberty they ever made."
-It cost me a whole $9.
-We also talked backstage about
that you were very lucky to do
back-to-back films where
you managed to get through
without any COVID shutdowns.
-Yes.
-Which is very hard this day
and age but possible
because people take it
so seriously, right?
The COVID protocols
in place are massive.
-I mean, it's important,
and I think, you know,
when it comes to
something like that,
the rules really stem
from the top, you know?
Playing Spider-Man on set, you
have a responsibility to follow
the rules so that everyone else
sees you doing it
so they copy you.
That said, there were times
that we would have a bit of fun
with it.
I remember in
the Spider-Man suit,
because the thing is so tight,
the zip sometimes gets stuck.
And it's a nightmare.
I'll have like half of it off,
and I'm like, "Please, just get
this thing off of me."
And we have a bottle of lube
that we, like, squirt on
the zip to, like, get it open
and stuff.
-Yeah, that's why we have one,
too, yeah.
-That's why we have
bottles of lube.
-Yeah, because zippers.
-Right.
But anyway, we were on set,
and Mitch Bell was there.
Mitch Bell is one of our
big Marvel producers.
He's in charge of the money, so,
you know, like, a COVID shutdown
for him is a very serious thing
and he's taking it
very seriously.
And this bottle of lube
does suspiciously
look like a bottle of
hand sanitizer.
So, he walks over and he's
chatting to me, and he's like,
"Hey, man, can I get some of
that hand sanitizer?"
And I look at my brother Harry,
and I'm like, "This is about to
be golden."
[ Laughter ]
So, I'm squeezing all this stuff
on him.
I'm squeezing it, squeezing it,
squeezing it, and he walks off,
and you can see him on set like,
"This goddamn hand sanitizer
won't go."
[ Laughter ]
And then the best thing --
At the end of the day,
the same thing happened with
the boom op.
So, he's doing a scene,
and I can see him like this.
He's like,
"I can't hold on to the boom."
[ Laughter ]
"It's so slippery everywhere."
I promise that's the only two
times we did it, though.
-That's right.
The idea of you half in a
Spider-Man suit, I don't know --
Have you ever gone to
the "Sesame Street" studios?
-I have not.
-'Cause the one thing
they tell you is, like, you
cannot take any photos of,
like, the muppets,
like, at rest, right,
'cause it would be
too terrifying for children.
-Sitting there with a beer,
like, smoking a cigarette.
-Or it's just like,
you know, like that.
[ Laughter ]
-Right, right, right.
Just a dead muppet.
-Yeah.
I feel like the same about --
like, I would never want to see
a photo of, like, Spider-Man
half in and out of his suit,
just having given up.
-It's not attractive.
It's not flattering.
And it also comes with
a lot of me being like,
"Get it off! Get it off!
Get it off!"
I've got, like, the neck stuck
over my mouth.
I'm suffocating.
Director's giving me notes.
It's just -- It's a tough time.
-Well, the good news is
it pays off on screen.
We're going to be right back
with more from Tom Holland
after this.